parce que j'aime en pleine réunion miami
diot excuses du terrain c'est parce que
je sais pas quel rythme se faisait pour
le seul à cocher
on dort mal après le bye bye 2016 2017
mais pas en 2012
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous
d'embarquer à nouveau dans cette
aventure le temps petit moi j'ai enfin
fini de dominique michel denise
filiatrault que je suis partout s'est
mise idole et ce l'est encore d'une
certaine façon je vois ces femmes leur
avance et puis je les aime j trouve
belle je les trouve inspirant petit je
rêvais quand peut-il de faire un bye bye
un jour et puis quand quand on m'a
demandé de le faire j'ai dit oui après
ça j'ai dit non après ça je ne suis pas
sûr il ya comme une espèce de panique
qui s'installe à ce qu'on se dit je veux
être capable je pensais que je pourrais
mais je sais pas à quoi ça ressemble
l'intérieur donc évidemment j'ai dit oui
puis je suis revenu mais voilà et si
france beaudoin voici quelques-uns des
meilleurs non non vous êtes une
comédiens de pluriel parce que vous avez
jouer toutes sortes de rôles au théâtre
au cinéma et à la télévision
moi je vous ai connu dans chambres en
ville le rôle de lola
or plus dramatiques ou si j'étais
épuisée je n'ai plus la nuitée j'ai pas
envie de recommencer cette nouvelle mais
vous est aussi connu dans l'humour qu'on
pense à au coeur a ses raisons
les bobos les parents aussi
quand même un peu oui est ce que ces
deux facettes d'une même personne qu'est
ce qui vous branche le plus dans une
affaire tout mettre le reste la comédie
le drame la tragédie sa part sa part du
ventre à chaque fois c'est la même chose
c'est même travail est souvent quand on
fait de la comédie dans le processus des
répétitions tout ça on est souvent plus
angoissés quand on fait de la grosse des
grandes tragédies grecques ques et c'est
curieux au théâtre aussi j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de grosses tragédie de gros
drame est souvent aux ouvriers beaucoup
plus en répétition que quand on a joué
de la comédie par exemple c'est très
curieux
tu croyais bon garçon que cet homme
qu'on me donne était pour les bogies de
ton mairie c'est bizarre on dirait que
la comédie ça en fait ça pardonne pas
pendant les répétitions même à la télé
on a pas de public notre premier public
bon ça va être les techniciens une fois
qu on leur répétait une fois puis qui
ont ri la deuxième la troisième fois
mené personnes qui rit a lancé c'est
donc pas cette nourriture auditive
baisse est facile de tomber dans la
paranoïa et de dire mon dieu je suis
trop c'est donc bien plate j'ai pas le
bon rythme j'ai pas et à partir du
moment où on ne paie aucune assurance
belle tout s'écroule ça prend ça prend
l'assurance alors chaque année ça draine
et moi on va passer deux semaines tant
sur le port de la mer beaucoup
d'admiration pour votre complicité avec
une hargne quand la télévision qu'à la
radio
est-ce que dès la première rencontre
vous êtes dit soc ça va cliquer ça va
fonctionner et on se dit pas on sent des
choses on sent que yanis parenté que max
est un peu une bougie d'allumage
meetic dès qu'on ait un côté de l'autre
se passe des choses dans ce lot des
niaiseries on se met à danser on chante
on ne sait pas pourquoi cru comme ça cet
automne vous avez participé au tournage
du prochain film de xavier dolan
c'étaient des retrouvailles cinq ans
après mon ami juste un an
oui ça a été des retrouvailles mais
comme non il retrouvera en même temps
que xavier je le vois trois fois par
semaine et on se voit constamment
s'appelle presque tous les jours donc
c'est ce sont des retrouvailles
professionnelle mais mais c'était bien
le système vient surtout de pouvoir
jouer avec lui ce qui nous était pas
arrivé depuis j'y suis la mère en fait
on avait joué ensemble pour cent dans
les amours imaginaires mais oui on est
on est des amis on est des amis vous
avez déjà dit que vous n'aimez pas vous
voir à l'écran
non que vous avez peur de la mort c'est
pas plus contradictoires alors que vous
pratiquez un métier où tout est question
d'image
oui j'ai dit souvent que j'avais peur de
la mort ça m'inquiète pas ça mutile de
moins en moins comme comme je vieillis
plus j'ai pas proche de la mort de plus
en plus est ce que c'est une
c'est de plus en plus envahissants cette
question là mais mais en même temps le
fait de de découvrir
d'autres personnes de l'intérieur en les
incarnant de changer de vie tout le
temps moi ça me
ça me sort de quelque chose entre que ça
me sort de moi et ça me fait le plus
grand bien
parce que j'ai pas assez de ma vie à moi
je trouve même si elle est bien rempli
ce passé elle est intéressante ma vie
mais j'ai mis en avoir mille que justin
homme normal merci beaucoup merci à vous
en avez dominé chez vous si bonne année
qui enfin de la mer ont répété pape même
menacé